[Music]
on this thursday night making more
promises about climate change canada and
california's new pact the bottom line is
we're delivering what matters to people
why critics fear it's all talking not
enough action historic prime time public
hearings into the u.s capital attack
what those caught up in it are expecting
i'm watching for the truth
and the promise to prove who was at the
center of it russia's war in ukraine
fueling famine russia is
is clearly weaponizing food the
impending global food crisis
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is no more pressing issue
affecting every living thing on earth
than the changing climate and our
political leaders have made lots of
promises on how to address it today
there were more prime minister justin
trudeau is in los angeles he met there
privately with the u.s president joe
biden and with california governor gavin
newsom the two signing what they call a
memorandum of cooperation to work
together on things like clean tech
conserving biodiversity dealing with
wildfires and zero emission
transportation california is running out
of time it's entering the third
consecutive summer of severe drought in
what is the driest year on record though
it's only early june there's already a
severe water shortage in southern
california water restrictions have been
imposed on millions of people in some
cities lawns can be watered once a week
for eight minutes only rule breakers
face hefty fines and farmers in some
regions have been ordered to stop
drawing water from rivers and streams
the window to avoid the worst impacts of
climate change is narrowing fast so what
difference will agreement with
california make our chief political
correspondent david aiken is traveling
with the prime minister and has our top
story tonight
justin trudeau and gavin newsom two
progressive politicians who like each
other who each lead jurisdictions of
about 40 million people and who are
convinced governments must do more to
fight climate change on climate action
the world is watching i'm here for a
reason proud to be standing side by side
with the prime minister of canada on
this issue
and they're now building on earlier
canada california agreements to reduce
greenhouse gas emissions by signing a
new climate action and nature protection
partnership they say it will benefit
people in both jurisdictions we're
delivering what matters to people
clean air and water
good jobs and a strong future
one new area of cooperation fighting
increasingly frequent and severe
wildfires that have caused immense
damage in california but also in
provinces like bc and alberta now the
two jurisdictions will formalize plans
to share best practices and exchange
research and information to prevent
fires and minimize future damage critics
though say this new agreement is yet
another example from the trudeau
government that amounts to more talk
than actual action i think we do need to
start seeing actual action on the ground
for some of these things
rather than sort of agreements canada's
environment commissioner for example has
consistently given the trudeau liberals
failing grades on its climate plans in
part because canada is one of the
world's biggest oil and gas producers
the prime minister says that cannot be
an excuse for not pushing ahead yeah
canada is a big oil and gas producing
company country and
because of that not in spite of that
we are
leading on climate change as well
both these leaders remember a liberal
and a democrat were asked how these
environment agreements might survive if
their governments are replaced by say a
conservative or republican government
that may have different views on climate
change and their answer these agreements
give certainty to private sector
corporations to make investments in new
factories and new hires in clean
technology and that private sector
momentum is very hard for future
governments to reverse
donna david aiken in los angeles tonight
thanks at the same time as the prime
minister was making more climate pledges
in california his government continues
to push ahead with a deep water oil
field off newfoundland and labrador in
april the bay de nord project 500
kilometers east of st john's was
approved now there are growing questions
about whether the federal and provincial
liberal governments are moving in
opposite directions on the environment
ross lord explains
higher oil prices mean newfoundland and
labrador's offshore oil and gas industry
is on the upswing again and saint john's
harbor could be seeing even more of
these supply ships and their towering
presence you will see this harbor much
busier when baidu nor comes on you'll
see the skies busier with the
helicopters the restaurants the stores
downtown the bay de nord project is in
the flemish pass about 500 kilometers
east of st john's it's immense the
developer ecuanor says it will cost 16
billion dollars canadian to develop over
several decades the oil field would
produce an estimated 500 million barrels
and create the equivalent of sixteen
thousand jobs it's an unusual time for
an oil mega project with canada
supposedly going green to counter the
devastating effects of climate change
and yet the federal government has
approved bay de nord a decision that
makes no sense to environmentalists
canada is absolutely trying to do two
things at one time this memorial
university instructor says it's time for
a clean break from fossil fuel
industries this trying to walk the
environment industry divide
is
is highly problematic and it's burning
the planet it makes canada a bad actor
in climate change in the international
stage
a coalition of environmental groups is
suing the federal government saying
environment minister stephen gebo
dropped the ball it's our position that
downstream greenhouse gas emissions are
one such effect he has to consider
when he makes that decision and in this
case he didn't do that he didn't look at
those effects the government says bayden
ord will be subject to the strongest
greenhouse gas conditions ever in canada
and emissions will be far below average
the prime minister insists there's no
contradiction what we're seeing with
europe what we're seeing
around the world is a need to transform
our energy mix to remove
the carbon emissions from it and that's
uh that's the direction we're going in
not not backwards bay de nord is not a
done deal equinor has other options to
consider in other parts of the world and
now the provincial government wants to
discuss with the company how much money
would flow into this province
if the scope has increased
we feel that our
our take should increase our people
should benefit from it it's our resource
ecuador told global news it anticipates
making a final decision within the next
couple of years with production plan by
the end of the decade
ross lord global news st johns
canada post is unveiling its plan to
reach net zero emissions though the
company's ceo says it won't get there
until 2050.
we know we need to move faster on this
at canada post we understand
the complete urgency of reducing
emissions in canada and for that matter
across the globe
doug ettinger says canada post's
challenge in going green is how much
ground they cover the first priority he
says is transforming its fleet making
its 14 thousand vehicles 50 percent
electric by 2030 and fully electric by
2040 some low emission vehicles are
already being tested in the ottawa area
the department of national defense is
looking for potential impacts after a
cyber attack on a military contractor
believed to have been carried out by a
ransomware group with ties to russia dnd
says the contractor cmc electronics
disclosed a cyber breach late last month
the montreal-based business does
millions of dollars of work for the
canadian armed forces last week it was
announced as part of a team upgrading
canada's ch-146 griffin helicopters in a
statement cmc's parent company confirms
a third-party intrusion into its network
that it says disrupted operations in
connection with a ransom demand
there is no indication the hackers stole
sensitive information dnd says none of
its internal systems employ cmc
technology you can read more about this
and the group believed to be behind it
on our website globalnews.ca
global national
now to washington history is unfolding
in prime time tonight as the committee
investigating the january sixth attack
on the u.s capitol begins public
hearings the committee says it will tell
the story of a conspiracy to overturn
the 2020 presidential election and block
the peaceful transfer of power it
promises detailed new evidence that it
will be released that will connect the
dots between former president donald
trump and the attempted insurrection
jackson proskow on the hype around these
hearings and what's expected
the most detailed account of the attempt
to overthrow an american election comes
from inside the very building that came
under attack with days of hearings
revealing volumes of new evidence
including testimony from those closest
to former president donald trump like
his daughter ivanka
it was a multi-level multi-step process
of trying to
negate nullify and destroy
joe biden's majority in electoral
college the committee investigating
january 6 carried out hundreds of
interviews and amassed thousands of
documents focusing on the rioters the
planning and the role of trump and his
election lies you don't concede when
there's theft involved
the agonizing screams of officer daniel
hodges are part of that dark body of
evidence
he was brutally crushed while trying to
defend the capital from the mob
i'm watching for the truth i want to
know i want to know what happened i want
to who knew who what where when why
no matter how damning the evidence the
committee will have to overcome
republican efforts to rewrite history
those who insist there's nothing to
investigate
in fact it is the most political
and least legitimate committee in
american history americans remain split
over the attack on their democracy when
it comes to finding out what happened
polls show 89 percent of democrats say
it's important only 52 percent of
republicans feel the same watching all
the politicians say that it wasn't a big
deal that no one needs to pay attention
to it that it's a political witch hunt
especially when it's so obvious that
that's not the case
i don't know
how they can do that for all the
anticipated revelations less explosive
details may be the most critical in
preventing a repeat of that horrible day
like the role of fake pro-trump electors
or efforts to interfere in state voting
certifications if you want to say what
are we trying to do to protect the
system from a recurrence some of those
things that seem abstract and maybe a
little bit technical and boring may
actually be the most important part of
the hearings the divide is not only over
how americans perceive the events of
january 6th it also extends to where
they can watch the historic hearings
unfold every single u.s tv network is
carrying tonight's hearings with one
notable exception fox news the top rated
choice of trump's republican voter base
donna jackson proskow in washington
thanks the u.s house of representatives
is once again taking up gun legislation
a day after it voted to pass some
sweeping gun control legislation
no child
no parent
deserves
to live in fear of gun violence
the democrat-led house passed a bill
today to nationalize red flag laws which
seek to keep guns away from individuals
deemed a threat to themselves and others
last night it passed legislation that
raises the minimum age for purchasing a
semiautomatic weapon from 18 to 21 and
bans civilian use of high-capacity
magazines
though the proposals have almost no
chance of being approved by the senate
and actually becoming law
an apology from a senior military leader
coming up how one of his social media
posts is causing controversy
eight days after the federal government
unveiled former supreme court justice
louise arbor's scathing report on sexual
misconduct in the canadian forces a
social media post by a senior military
leader is raising questions about the
real commitment to culture change our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
has the story mercedes
donna the comment was made by major
general simon bernard he's the head of
the military's hr department and someone
who in that role obviously has a key and
important role to play in culture change
for the forces many survivors of sexual
misconduct were upset to see him among
the dozens of people taking part last
weekend in a grassroots social media
campaign in support of canada's military
colleges bernard changed his linkedin
profile picture to his royal military
college graduation photo and commented
tdv on a post written by another
graduate that stands for truth duty
valor or mc's motto survivors felt that
that didn't show any mindfulness on
bernard's part further proof they think
that change at the college will be hard
to come by in her report justice louise
arbor said canada's military colleges
were institutions quote from a different
era plagued by what she called a
discriminatory culture
none of it sits well with mark popov
he's a former senior military officer
who also used to lead officer cadet
training at rmc kingston
the reactionary viewpoint that i'm
seeing on social media is disappointing
from a lot of people that i that i know
personally because
justice arbor is not attacking them
is not attacking the institution of rmc
but it is pointing out some flaws that
exist and identifying the need for some
changes
bernard later deleted his comment and
removed his graduation photo after being
challenged by several women who said
they were assaulted and harmed at the
military colleges in a statement to
global news bernard said quote
though there was no ill intent in my
post i accept accountability for what in
hindsight i did not consider the impact
on others and i sincerely apologize to
anyone who has been affected it's not
the first time though that bernard's
judgment has been questioned he was
removed last year from his role in
canada's vaccine rollout task force
after being accused of using a racial
slur the n-word while at work sometime
in the year 2020. dnd said that two
investigations did not produce enough
evidence to go further despite that
bernard was still later promoted to the
rank of major general donna okay
mercedes stevenson in ottawa thanks
war and hunger ahead the link between
russia's aggression and a global food
crisis
you're watching global national
[Music]
a naval blockade on ukraine's southern
port is having a serious impact on grain
exports before russia's invasion
millions of tons of grain and produce
was shipped from ukraine each month as
dan spector reports russia is now being
accused of weaponizing food
one of them this year the time 100 gala
is back to gleaming with glitz and
glamour but as it celebrated its annual
list of the world's most influential
people it was a guest of honor who
couldn't attend that provided the
biggest impact
millions of people may starve if
russia's blockade of the black sea
continues in accepting his honor
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
also spoke directly about the crisis
still gripping his people and
underscored the potential for a
catastrophic global food crisis if
ukrainian grain exports don't soon
restart russia is
is clearly weaponizing food
the ongoing war between russia and
ukraine the world's third and fourth
largest grain exporters has fueled food
price inflation and put global grain
supplies at risk developing countries
are the hardest hit civil unrest is
already intensifying in countries like
sri lanka
where police clashed with protesters
again thursday
the united nations compares the looming
famine to a gathering storm
ukraine's food production and the food
and fertilizer produced by russia
must be brought back into world markets
despite the war
the un is working with turkey trying to
broker a deal to lift russia's blockade
of ukraine's ports
we see it as a reasonable and
implementable plan said turkey's foreign
minister after meeting with his russian
counterpart though talks have been
described as fruitful so far there has
been no breakthrough after weeks of
bargaining
the russian side as usual is playing its
stupid games said ukraine's ambassador
to turkey ukrainian officials claim the
kremlin is imposing unreasonable
conditions
russia says free shipment depends on an
end to western sanctions here at home
access to food is not in danger but
prices will continue to rise sylvan
charles points to a potential peak this
fall dan spectre global news montreal
that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen tonight's
your canada is spillers cove
newfoundland and labrador we'd love to
see your canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching farah nasser will be
at the anchor desk tomorrow and i'll see
you saturday for the new reality
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you